عدد من الاصابات في الساعات الماضيه وحسب
الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى الان
2825 ضابط وجندي اصيبوا منذ بدايه
الحرب بالفعل عثمان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما
زال يمنى بقتلى وجرحى في معارك قطاع غزه
وفي اخر تحديث للجيش الاسرائيلي يشير
الجيش الى ان خمسه من جنوده وضباطه اصيبوا
في معارك قطاع غزه وهذا يعني بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يبنى بهذه الخسائر وان
المعارك ما زالت على اشدها الساعه الاخيره
حملت معها تحليقا كثيفا للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في الاجواء الشماليه لقطاع غزه
حيث اغارت هذه المقاتلات على اكثر من موقع
تحديدا في الضواحي الجنوبيه والجنوبيه
الغربيه لمدينه غزه بعض هذه الغارات
استهدفت مناطق قريبه جدا من السياج الامني
وكانت كما يبدو تستهدف تدمير المباني
والمنشات التجاريه والصناعيه القريبه من
السياج الامني تلك المناطق التي يرى فيها
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه ضمن رؤيته الامنيه
يجب ان تكون منطقه امنيه عازله بعد انتهاء
الحرب ويحدث فيها دمارا كبيرا كما قام
بعمليه تفجير كبيره في تلك المنطقه على
الاقل في الساعه الاخيره من ناحيه اخرى
بين الحين والاخر ايضا تسمع اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله احيانا تاتي من
الجهه الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه واحيانا اخرى
في المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه دا عن ذلك
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه ما زال يواصل
عملياته العسكريه في المناطق الشماليه
والوسطى لقطاع غزه لكن نسق ونمط هذه
العمليات يختلف عن نصق وعمليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في المناطق الجنوبيه حيث ان
العمليات العسكريه في هذه المنطقه بعد ان
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بان العمليات
الكبرى قد انتهت هي عمليات محدوده ايه في
الزمان وفي المكان وفي الاهداف وهي مبنيه
بالاساس على معلومات استخباراتيه اي يريد
الجيش الاسرائيلي من خلالها الوصول احيانا
الى مخازن اسلحه او الى منصات اطلاق
صواريخ او الى معاقله تابعه للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه لم يصلها خلال المعارك الكبرى
فيما ان الفرقه 98 ما زالت تعمل في
المنطقه الجنوبيه بزخم كبير وتحت امرتها
خمسه الويه تعمل في منطقه خان يونس بعض
التقديرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه تشير الى
ان الجيش الاسرائيليه وخلال اسبوع واحد
ربما ينهي زخم عملياته الكبرى في منطقه
خانيونس
عفوا وربما بعد ذلك السؤال الذي يطرح الى
اين سيتوجه هل سيتوجه الى رفح والى
المناطق الحدوديه مع الجانب المصري لكن
هذا ما يطالب الجيش الاسرائيلي على الاقل
بمعرفته من المستوى السياسي الذي لم يتخذ
قرارا بعد فيما اذا كان سيوسع من عملياته
العسكريه الى منطقه رفح والى المنطقه
الحدوديه مع الجانب المصري شكرا جزيلا لك
الياس كرام من غلاف غزه واسماعيل الغول
ايضا الذي كان معنا